y aquí tenemos la gráfica fx y queremos
conocer tres límites diferentes como
siempre pausa en este vídeo y vean si
pueden resolverlo ustedes son los
primero antes de resolverlo juntos bien
primero pensemos en cuál es el límite de
fx cuando x se aproxima a 6 entonces
vamos a ver cuando x se aproxima a 6
desde ambos lados conforme nos
aproximamos a 6 desde la izquierda es
decir desde valores menores a 6 parece
que nuestra efe de x se aproxima a 1 y
conforme nos acercamos a x igual a 6
desde la derecha parece ser que nuestra
efe de x nuevamente se aproxima a 1 y
para que este límite exista necesitamos
aproximarnos al mismo valor tanto desde
el lado derecho como desde el lado
izquierdo aquí lo tenemos bueno al menos
gráficamente nunca podemos estar seguros
únicamente con la gráfica pero esta es
una buena estimación
si nos aproximamos a un no escribiré de
un color más oscuro 1 ahora veamos el
límite de fx cuando x se aproxima a 4
entonces qué pasa cuando nos acercamos a
4 desde la izquierda bueno conforme nos
aproximamos a 4 desde el lado izquierdo
parece ser que nuestra función se
aproxima a 3 y recuerden que puede
existir un límite en un valor x en donde
la función por sí misma no está definida
por ejemplo podemos decir que después de
4 no está definida pero parece que
cuando nos aproximamos a x igual a 4
desde la izquierda se ve que f se
aproxima a 3 y cuando nos aproximamos a
4 desde la derecha nuevamente vemos que
nuestra función se aproxima a 3 entonces
al menos de lo que podemos obtener de la
gráfica podemos notar que el límite de
fx cuando x se aproxima a 4 es
aun cuando la función todavía no está
definida ahora pensemos en el límite
cuando x se aproxima a 2 esto es muy
interesante porque miren la función y si
está definida sobre 2 entonces vamos a
ver cuando nos aproximamos desde el lado
izquierdo parece que nuestra función se
aproxima al valor de 2 pero cuando nos
aproximamos a x igualados desde el lado
derecho
nuestra función se acerca más y más a 5
no llega a 5 pero conforme pasamos de
2.1 a 2.01 y a 2.001 parece ser que el
valor de nuestra función se acerca más y
más a 5 entonces como nos aproximamos a
dos valores diferentes desde cada lado
es decir desde el lado izquierdo y desde
el lado derecho podemos decir que este
límite no existe entonces este límite no
existe
eso es muy interesante porque en el
primer caso la función y el límite son
iguales miren en este primer caso la
función está definida en 6 y el límite
es igual al valor de la función en x
igual a 6 sin embargo aquí la función no
está definida en x igual a 4 pero el
límite existe aquí la función está
definida en x igualados pero el límite
no existe conforme nos aproximamos a x
igualados veamos otras funciones para
obtener los límites gráficamente aquí
tenemos la gráfica de jay cual ag de x
nuevamente pause en este vídeo y traten
de resolverlo ustedes primero ok aquí
tenemos el límite cuando x se aproxima a
5 deje de x entonces conforme nos
aproximamos a 5 desde el lado izquierdo
vemos que nos aproximamos a este valor
voy a dibujar una línea recta
nos aproximamos a este valor y conforme
nos acercamos a 5 desde el lado derecho
parece ser que también nos acercamos a
ese mismo valor así que a simple vista
parece que este valor es 0.4 entonces
podemos decir que el límite
definitivamente existe porque cuando
observamos la gráfica aunque no es muy
preciso podemos decir que es de
aproximadamente 0.4 podría ser 0.41 o
0.45 6789
no podemos saber exactamente si sólo
analizamos la gráfica pero parece que el
valor se encuentra aproximadamente por
aquí ok ahora pensemos en el límite de g
de x cuando x se aproxima a 7 hagamos lo
mismo que pasa cuando nos aproximamos
desde la izquierda es decir desde
valores menores a 7 como por ejemplo 6.9
6.99 6.999
bueno parece ser que el valor de nuestra
función se aproxima a 2 no importa que
la función real esté definida como g de
7 igual a 5 porque conforme nos
aproximamos desde la izquierda cuando x
pasa de 6.9 a 6.99 y así sucesivamente
vemos que el valor de nuestra función se
aproxima a 2 y conforme nos aproximamos
a x igual a 7 desde el lado derecho
parece que ocurre lo mismo nos
aproximamos a 2 entonces podemos decir
que esto es igual a 2 nuevamente la
función está definida aquí y el límite
existe pero g de 7 es diferente al valor
del límite deje de x cuando x se
aproxima a 7
ok hagamos uno más cuál es el límite
cuando x se aproxima a uno bueno podemos
hacer lo mismo desde el lado izquierdo
parece ser que la función es no a
contable conforme x pasa de 0.9 a 0.99
0.900 99 y 0.9 1999 esto es notable
tiende a infinito y miren conforme nos
aproximamos desde el lado derecho ocurre
lo mismo la función es no a contable
tiende a infinito bueno informalmente
muchas veces solamente dicen que se
aproxima a infinito pero si queremos ser
más formales sobre lo que significa un
límite en este contexto como es notable
podemos decir que no existe
no existe